the phones are jammed at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 let's go to our first caller from the
9 7 9 area code caller from 9 7 9 who's
this this is John competing go ahead
John David I had a question for you and
I wanted to get your thoughts on just
the personal growth aspect of the people
that that lead us and I had a friend a
friend of mine she's a woman who grew up
together very very close and we're
having a conversation about this so at
what point do we forgive people and
there's different levels of wrong like
in terms of Al Franken sure and someone
like Roy Roy Moore Al Franken is not
really more should we did we over punish
do we shoot ourselves in the foot and as
progressives when do we start taking
into account that we actually have made
some personal growth in our lives like
Franken took accountability for what he
did and he owned it and you know maybe
we maybe we went too far I just wanted
to get your thoughts this on on that if
it maybe we did go too far and if we
hold ourselves to a different standard
than then then right-wingers would hold
themselves you know they yeah I gotta
have fun so the left definitely holds
itself to a different standard I mean we
see that when nobody on the Left was
defending Anthony Weiner when he had his
scandal you had people you know even
with Bill Clinton like we were talking
about with one alleged exception you're
talking about consensual incidents that
were inappropriate in different ways
with Al Franken you were talking about
something that is you know 1% of what
Brett Kavanaugh was accused of and yet
you did have Democratic senators saying
he should resign so I don't know if the
answer is that the left should stop
holding people accountable it's that we
need to expose the hypocrisy here and
merely exposing it won't do anything
because the thing is the right doesn't
care the right doesn't care about the
hypocrisy as long as they can keep
putting the people they want in the
Senate in governor's man dies in the
Supreme Court so it's really there's the
there's the moral question which is
Democrats if they are still if they are
willing to do what's right when it comes
to these allegations they should
continue doing it for moral reasons and
then we also need to have sort of the
pragmatic discussion which is was it
right to call for frankenz resignation
in that particular case and and that's
sort of a question you've got to answer
on a one-on-one case-by-case basis I
agree it's a machine
watching him go down because we were we
were saying that he admitted he admitted
to everything that he did he owned it
and you know said that you know gave a
bullet point of things that he did wrong
and I think that in that particular case
you're right I think we should go
case-by-case on it but it you know it
kind of looks like on the other side
like oh they just give them a pass but
that's not the case so I think people
need to be a little bit more more aware
that everything is on a case-by-case
basis and you know some people don't
take accountability and there are
different levels of wrong there are and
so there are yep John thank you I got
everyone I got a ton of people holding
but an important topic and I appreciate
hearing from you about it